So the quiz we just did shows that
adding more cores might result in a slow
down if we have to stay
within the same power budget.
But, this is only true if we cannot
adjust the voltage and frequency, so
that when there is no parallelism
available we boost the frequency of
the one or two active cores so that they
get the full power budget of the chip.
Modern processors do this.
Let's look at an example
of Intel's core I7-4702MQ.
Which was released in
the second quarter of 2013.
It's a mobile processor, so
it's design power is only 37 watts.
That's what we can pull in a laptop,
apparently.
It has four cores.
And, it's normal clock when using
all four cores is 2.2 GHz maximum.
It can actually save power because it
might operate on a battery by reducing
this frequency even when
running all four cores.
But the processor has a turbo frequency
of 3.2 GHz when running only one core.
That frequency is 1.45
times the normal frequency.
If we assume that the power
increases cubically with this,
then we will get three times the power.
So we are not using four times
the power of a single core,
which we should be able to
get because it's four cores.
So when operating
one-quarter of the cores,
that one-quarter of the cores
can get four times the power.
We're only getting three times, so
the question is why not four times.
Well, because it's not only
about the overall chip power.
What's really happening is that if
we have a relatively large chip and
we have four cores on it, let's say.
And we keep heating up
this part of the chip,
the heat will spread into
other parts of the chip.
But this one will still be
hotter than the others.
So if we're spending power
evenly across the chip,
we can spend more power than if we
spent it all in one corner of the chip.
Because if we spread the power around,
then the chip overall gets hotter.
If we spend all power in the same place,
then that place gets
a lot hotter than before.
So that's why three times and
not four times.
Because at three times the power this
part of the chip achieves similar
temperatures to those achieved by
spreading the heat around at 2.2 GHz.
Let's look at another example
which is Intel's core I7-4771.
It's a similar processor released
in third quarter of 2013.
So they're relatively similar in
terms of technology and so on.
But this is not a laptop processor,
its design power is much higher.
84 watts.
It's also has 4 cores.
But the normal clock of
a core is now 3.5 GHz.
Much larger than in
the mobile processor.
The turbo clock,
when running only one core, is 3.9 GHz.
Or only 11% above normal.
And if we assume that the power is
cubically growing with frequency,
that means it's only spending 1.38
times the power of a core when
working with three other cores.
Why is it like that?
Well, because this being a normal bell
processor has much better cooling,
so it can cool the chip when
operating at this high power.
But that also means that the chip
is already pretty hot and
getting it even slightly hotter
in any place very quickly reaches
the temperatures at which
it's dangerous for the chip.
So we could only really spend
this much more power in one core
even though the others are not working.
So pretty much what's happening is,
when running at
four cores the chip is very
close to not being able to cool.
If we turbo boost a particular part
of the chip, it gets even hotter and
we can only afford a little bit more of
heat before we run into cooling issues.
Even though the heat is kind of leaking
to the cooler parts of the chip it's
just not doing it enough.
And this is pretty typical
that cores designed for
lower power have more flexibility
in shifting that power.
Whereas, if we are near
the limits of what we can do,
then really shifting the power so
that it can all be consumed in one
corner very quickly gets that one
corner of the chip to overheat.